[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réputé le match était loin par m
[Applaudissements]
sa main et ça n'en est pas un mais deux
jours que j'attends dans ce très bien le
début le député machin tout maintenant
vous êtes énervé
donc vous avez vous réconciliez vous
détendre bois un petit couteau puis ça
va lui met deux heures que j'assure
occasion française moi je me suis dit oh
toi j'ai un petit peu déçue ce soit vrai
je crois que tu ressors oui parce que je
regarde un petit peu l'émission avant
les chasseurs doivent avant de venir et
je me suis dit ça va être bien je vais
en fait les marseillais contre dubaï
[Applaudissements]
et là j'arrive en dehors de cette barbe
aussi
vite possible en pensez quoi moi je
crois que toi de lui et [ __ ] ça lui va
bien je n'oublie
pas de la gorge il loupait venir ça ah
oui mais bon est-ce que je me change ah
oui ah oui oui un petit défi encore plus
non mais quelques jours d'un petit peu
plus vite
mais plus belle chemise
ça fait quoi évidemment j'ai jeu ça me
rappelle évidemment ce magnifique en
ajouter tiens regarde une des possibles
[Rires]
a dit parce qu'on a on a un gros gros
gros dossiers on a beaucoup de choses à
faire on n'a pas un temps fou à
limoges vient du rythme
de qui
[Applaudissements]
ah non le second thème vaguement
hippiques
mais dans mes rêves qui conseille quand
même conseil qui bat tous -
et concessionnaires présidente ou pas du
tout ay conseil bring aux mêmes à nu
mais bien c'est formidable
[Rires]
à
oui je suppose qu'on s'est plaint de
contrat après beaucoup d'argent beaucoup
d'argent mais après non mais après je
vous avez fait quoi cet été vous parle
j'ai envie de savourer fait quoi ce club
là où il a été à saint-tropez moi j'ai
pas été à saint-tropez du tout mais lui
dans les deux il était tout énormément
j'ai pas été à saint-tropez le fleuve
je suis très souvent en espagne sur une
petite j'adore les spa n'a que que que
j'aime bien nature en corse ah non ma
chance et
sinon c'est dès maintenant
chez lui c'était pas saint-tropez gt a
aussi
payé les pots vacances propice aux rêves
ou a eu de pluie non oui oui ou
pyla-sur-mer c'était dans la série c'est
bien parce qu'en plus c'était fort et
d'entre nous n'a
ni les actions même dans les baies
il ya eu aussi des laveries élus
- 2 / meeting et gagner de l'argent
n'est pas sale ces gentilles vous
rassurer c'est très bien enfin
s'intéresser à lui toute la soirée et
voilà d'autres organes bien aussi
isabelle
je préfère des femmes de l'émission way
to hell mais bien sûr tout
n'est pas bien et d'ailleurs est là et
merci de ne jamais des personnes d'un
certain mur à l'arrêt c'est barbetta
côté gauche mais si c'est le magnifique
du khalife alors que c'est toi le
khalife var est donc raté de plus en
plus gros c'était chez parce qu'elle
pose sur ces news vous parliez publié
des extraits de toi ah bon tu es con à
l'antenne mais
je suis tellement content de te voir
mais j'avais discuté un peu avec toi en
fait je devais venir comme ça oui
comment ça va toi bien il est bientôt
heureux au bo heureux oui j'ai tourné
ensemble non j'ai tourné le bon dieu de
sa belle semaine
jusqu'au mois de février ça sort d'où
début et je me suis beaucoup amusé à son
cou t'amuser avec philippe de chauveron
le réalisateur dit de chevron avec le
tout les beaux parents en plus parce que
tu es là
mais non ils ne dirigent pas pour
raconter l'histoire sinon il va m'en
vouloir mais je dirais que et il a bien
bien le 3 va être très réussie m'a déjà
les deux étaient preuve oui mais cela va
être très très soit une pose des
questions et je réponds source
non c'est
non j'aimerais pouvoir terminer mon avis
non c'est à dire que le pays organise
pour no 88 ans de mariage non 20 comme
porno de des noces importante de faire
venir demande alors à leur mari de faire
venir toute belle famille ah voilà donc
je me bloque tout des besnard ouais
non pas l'horreur mais s'il veut ça nous
permet de vendre un film et bonjour à
nantes était certainement d'accueil
donc voilà c'est vrai donc je sais je
sais que philippe de chauveron je sais
pas si je te l'avais dit m'avait demandé
de jouer dans le 1 oui je le savais et
eut refusé parce que c'est un abruti
devient une habitude tu aurais dû le
faire parce qu'il voulait que tu joues
dans quoi hansen bâches et plus et chez
plus malheureux c'était pas la bar
mitzvah cissé savez ça qu'il fallait le
faire tu vas y est voilà mes philippe ou
la kek et qu'un amour de mec est donc ça
va sortir en février bien sûr il est
très attendu non parce que j'ai tourné
pendant l'été est là sinon c'est quoi
c'est quoi ta vivre
moi je vais écrire
deux trois choses et puis après j'ai bin
oui et puis après je veux retourner
probablement un peu d'année prochaine si
on m'appelle enfin bien sûr qu'on arrête
non mélangé on verra beaucoup de trucs
encore certaines choses qui ne me
plaisent pas ah oui je te m'envoyer un
truc à deux enjeux toujours pas une
nouvelle annonce est faux parce que sa
jolie toujours donc non je lis toujours
et avec beaucoup d'intérêt donc ça la
série qu'est christian c'est vrai qu'il
m'a envoyé une merde
[Applaudissements]
c'est maintenant c'est pas vrai du tout
j'aurais bien éclatés en fait demandé de
jouer ce sont son rôle mais je voulais
pas de ton passé maintenant 4 mais
pourquoi cette barbe
c'est cette barre concept dérange non
mais ça ne me dérange pas mais ça a un
côté ils n'augmentent pas mais vous dis
à chaque fois mais je sais oui parce que
ça me fera qu'à ce jour il faut prier
quoique j'ai préféré ce rêve mais non
mais je ne sais pas tu es déjà la lève
toi
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est impossible on aimerait qu'ils
ne puissent naturel tout est apprêté la
pression c'est ben-hur du sénat
les quatre cheveux blancs quatre chevaux
blancs de manif avait fait c'est toi
c'est ça aussi c'est fait vibrer en ce
moment aurait pu jouer ben-hur des
lentilles
bac c'est vrai il rêve de faire du
cinéma bah oui vraiment
remake de chercher quoi
vous l'avez perdue cinéma j'aurais
vraiment vraiment si jamais ça vous
chante et plus dont
[Applaudissements]
les quatre conseils comme ça c'est vrai
tout ça donc ils arrivés là moi j'ai
arrêté maintenant seul pas réitérer
qu'elle aurait vécu des hauts et
christian belz idole absolue c'est à
dire plusieurs fois l'émission c'est
vraiment c'est le seul jeu aussi des
gens venaient d'infliger un mariage et à
me faire jouer comme à quoi rager ben je
verrais des cartons non mais de toucher
les choses fausses qui a fait le plus
d'entrées non mais c'est pas la question
très bon mais sans vraiment mais alors
là tu l'aies quoi cette petite péninsule
dans l'oreillette on te dit des phrases
en mode urgence ici parce que j'ai vu le
producteur qui était absolu attendu deux
heures
parce que le décor est sympa mais les
couloirs
sont ignobles
alors on vous met dans une loge petit
détail anecdotes savoureuses
on vous met loge la loge se faire
bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon on a cloud et il est classé
bien c'est donc impossible d'ouvrir un
jour ouvre des fenêtres on écrit on est
au deuxième et alban bon le doigt bon et
on vous a mis les papiers non quelqu'un
m'a dit derrière en passant appuyer sur
le bouton avec a sonné
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu un coup d'arrêt la ligne parce
que tu vas faire parce que son bébé
l'odyssée sénat veulent m'enfermer après
tu avais le producteur présent tu te dis
un truc louche
qu'à manger oui et non mais ça je mange
plus mon mac comme très bien vous jouez
plus moi j'ai plus largement je fais
c'est fini